hello wednesday june third I'm gamespot
news you're watching Chris waters here
to make good on a promise I made you
yesterday to talk about fallout 4 today
there's also going to be other news but
not a lot of it because when Bethesda
says they're going to talk about fallout
all other news kind of runs screen for
the vaults so they don't get scoured
from the news feed by the scorching fire
of that trailer you've watched like five
times already I like part with the dog
at long last fallout 4 has emerged from
the vault and we've got some details
about what all is going on in the post
apocalypse these days Boston location
confirmed dog companion confirmed
narrator Ron Perlman confirmed mr.
handies protectors and brahmins
confirmed confirmed confirmed the
flashing between time periods indicates
that pre and post catastrophe worlds may
be playable and this garage here looks a
lot like a workshop that might serve as
your home base fallout 4 is coming to pc
playstation 4 and xbox one only no last
gen versions here and Bethesda has said
that they will show more of the game
during their e3 press conference on
Sunday jun 14th in the meantime be sure
to check out danny Anandi's extensive
trailer breakdown on gamespot to delve
into all the secrets and speculation I
know it's hard to look past the swirling
news hurricane that is III right now but
if you could you'd see the vast calm
expanse of the summer release doldrums
well ps4 owners will be able to spend
those long months diving into planetside
2 if they so choose developer daybreak
game company announced a June twenty
third release date for the massive
multiplayer online shooter which came
out two and a half years ago on PC after
launch the developer said players can
look forward to frequent game updates
which will include deeper features
holiday events and content new in-game
marketplace items and much much more
quantum break is expected to make a
showing at Microsoft's e3 press
conference on Monday June fifteenth but
developer remedy has made news again
with a third high profile staff
departure in three weeks
CEO Matthias mill arena joins executive
producer Kyle vennen and head of
franchise development askari Harkonnen
on the list of now former remedy
employees whose names I am probably
pronouncing incorrectly mill arena is
headed to World of Tanks developer
wargaming and like his former co-workers
had only glowing things to say about the
future of remedy and quantum break but
with this staff turnover and a delay to
2016 how important is it for the time
bending shooter to make a strong showing
at this year's e3 let me know what you
think in the comments below lastly in
addition to hosting their own III press
conference Microsoft has signed up her
appearance at the pc gaming show a new
conference that's making its debut on
tuesday jun 16 xbox boss phil spencer
and other key members of the team will
appear during the show to talk about
gaming on Windows 10 which includes PCs
tablets phones xbox one and hollow lens
Microsoft and AMD are co-sponsoring the
pc gaming show and other companies
attending the event include blizzard
entertainment Square Enix and Creative
Assembly among others I have a feeling
that hollow lens and VR headsets will
feature pretty heavily at e3 this year
you think I don't know it could be a
little early from a consumer perspective
if they don't announce some fall release
dates we had a good talk about our e3
predictions on yesterday's episode of
the lobby if you're into that kind of
thing and if you're not alright thanks
for watching the news I'll see you
tomorrow